ni violent ni raciste ni hostile aux
médias mais plutôt solidaires et
déterminés les gilet jaune du haut doubs
ont choisi de se retrouver autour d'un
couscous géant pour faire passer le
message
la saucisse de morteau c'est vrai mais
le couscous est bon aussi dit puis on a
entre amis avec le couscous est bon
comme la barre de l'humour et de la
convivialité
le rendez vous d'aujourd'hui a montré
que la troupe des gilet jaune du haut
doubs garde ses soutiens j'ai pris ma
décision dans le quartier en chef
d'entreprise et ensuite nous aussi par
une partie de mon personnel
qui fait partie des gilet jaune vécu la
décision de soutenir ce mouvement dit
apporter une aide à l'aide logistique
une aide matérielle financer un méchoui
ou un couscous c'est sa façon à lui de
dire sa colère et son envie de voir les
choses changer
actuellement aujourd'hui un tiers dans
les antres de mes employés qui malgré
des salaires décents il s'avère à la
française puisqu'on peut faire la part
des choses en étant dans la bande du
haut doubs il ya les salaires
frontaliers il ya les salaires français
j'ai interne les employés qui saisit
tient des saisies sur salaire pour
diverses raisons
j'estime que c'est extrêmement pénible
sous les tentes installées pour
l'occasion ou les abris de fortune
chacun apporte donc sa pierre où ses
compétences pour que le mouvement dure
encore bien au delà du grand débat c'est
notre grand débat nous clairement vu que
celui qui est apportée par le
gouvernement voilà c'est de la
fumisterie est clairement un une pré
pré campagne électorale clairement
regonflés à bloc à chacun de ces rendez
vous festif les gilet jaune de
pontarlier ne doute pas que leur
mouvement peut durer encore très
longtemps